που δαζατόσα χρόνια στηαγκλίαμα εμπίζδην έτσι μαζί σουμέσασελίουσμεκαι θα μα θα περισσότερα και ποία ξεκίνησαν
που κμεγάλατα σοκοπετά κα να μσοολάτε μαλε τα έχει χκαι με επισκεφθηκε και ονει στο
βλαύκος οκριδή τότε καιταλιπά καμα διάφορα κάτι α μέχρι το ο για ακόσα είναι νηντανιά
που ήταν τυπόμπα το χρηματιστηρίου σε αυτό το διάστη άσου τον κρύβο κάθημερινά κουμάρκα σοτης
ζωή ότι δε θα θέλανα τα διάκλαάλο λεφ ολιάλεματιας κύπρο ανθομε καλά ναι η λογική
μου το εέλικίασμας ου τοπό έτσ σημείωσι ότι με έχαν φτάσει στο μάστερ στο σκάγι
χαφέρισοπαλία με των καρπόστη ρουμανιά χαμε να καθημερινά μαθήματα με την μακαρέτηα την ελιζαβέ θα
πολύ χρονι τους και μου και αργότερα δγαπέντε χρόνια πρόεδρος τις κακεστικής όμως πονδές όπου
και την αναζαγώνι από τη καιτην όμως ποντέ αυτή σου το κρο πραα πάτεισα του
έ των τέσσερις φορές καιω το διάστημα και ότων το πράμα ντι είναι των το
πράμαβασνα είαι μια μάχι τις λογικής με το ζων εμείς οι άνθρωποι έχουμε νεραντρημερήείαι εγκέφαλο
οποίος απαρτίζεται από τον από τηλλογική της στυνιρότητα το ζωϊκό μέρος και το ερπετώ η
λογική μου χτυπούσε ά τώραπάμε άλει με στο πρόδριγόνο χριστό δουλίδες μαζί του εξιμίνες ένα
αλλάξο κύπρο ηλογική μου εκτυπούσε και υπάνω και έκαιο το νομό το ζω και τα
μας ούσε όλα κάτι παρόμιον που συμβαίννεικε αυτή που είναι αυτή τιστεμή βλέπουμε στο πρόσωπο
του γενιγού ελεκτί τον αγάπηε να ο κόσμος για κάποια πράγματα να το βάλωσε μιωσ
μια παρέθεση μετά να τα ούμεαθέλεις για τη λογική και κάποια πράματα πόγαμε αλλά το
ζων πυ έχει αγάημες είναι θύματα α εί μονές οναρκισισμός τούτα τα πράγματα διαλύσαντων και
βέψαντω εκτός δουιάείχες κάποιες υποθέσεις με το γενικό νααείνα α το φύγουμε γιατέ μεγάλον κεφάλεον